oh hi everybody and welcome back to game
life not today's episode we're going to
be talking about everybody's favorite
video game system the wii we're going to
head down a game developers conference
and talk to one of nintendo's developers
about we fit their new exercise game
that's coming out later this year and
then we're going to play some really
truly terrible wii games with Chris
Baker of Wired magazine I want you to
explain yourself Kohler were you drunk
at wondercon again yes I was
the Wii Balance Board is a wireless
device that sits on the floor on your
living room in front of your TV set and
it connects you over bluetooth to your
Nintendo Wii the killer app for the Wii
Balance Board is the wii fit and so
that's what we're showing off today
we're going to create your own personal
profile and the first time you do that
you're going to enter in your height and
your age and then you're going to have
your BMI checked kind of a snapshot of a
person's fitness and fitness level so
the first thing we do here is jump into
exercises do it and we're gonna we're
going to try a few different things now
we fit has over 40 different activities
okay under four main categories those
are strength training aerobics yoga and
balance games so really the full
spectrum something here for everybody
we fit is going to be available later
this year in May uh now some games that
are already available our games like
Anubis to and chicken shu chicken what
hahaha exactly see with the success of
the wii games like a nubes to chicken
shoot and all kinds of other terrible
$20 titles are actually all over the
shelves right now and we just want to
make sure that you don't buy them so
we're gonna play them so you don't have
to baker how you doing over there I'm
sorry so first up we have a nubes tube
from conspiracy entertainment the
conspiracy is that there was never an
Anubis one Havok physics engine the
render where software they use to make
GTA don't see how this could be bad I
want you to remember this loading screen
and menu because we will see it again
also this arrow this is without doubt
one of the top 10 best looking Atari
Jaguar games I've ever seen I love how
this rock has like seven polygons okay
so you use the nunchuck to jump by
swinging it upwards and in ten seconds
when you get tired of doing that you can
just use the Z button this reminds me of
like when I was ten and I was like oh
awesome all these two dollar Atari 2600
games the supermarket checkout line
score that lava looks like a delicious
pizza note that attacks only works
sometimes most people don't realize that
pyramids have bones inside of them okay
all together now grey grey sir reg racer
to another game that's a sequel to
nothing like the movie served
note that even though this game is from
a different publisher bowl games it has
the same loading screen and interface as
a new Miss to that's probably the
default option was making a game flash a
pic Optimus Prime if there's one nation
I associate with 18-wheel truck racing
its friends so now you steer using the
motion controls and that is about the
extent of the gameplay there's a break
and an e-brake which as far as i can
tell you the same thing this tree has
five polygons and I can't run it over my
big rig is no match for this tree don't
worry kids if you're having a problem
controlling your rig look the game's a I
can't do it either this crowd is just
sad it looks like a Jackson Pollock
painting
looks like you've made twenty dollars so
far right now i can afford rig racer
three whose cell shaded very winwaker
yeah oh wait it's actually 2d this is
actually swear to god the most expensive
game we're playing tonight chicken shoot
from dsi thirty dollars nice sinking
down the gun shots now we must be like
five miles away this basically looks
like a great like PC adventure game that
I buy in 1993 it's so brutal we like a
reading a book bang take that point
Dexter ah these levels just go on and on
when does it stop and of course the
chickens are just throwing eggs at you
all the while hey I'm figuring it out
this is actually an elaborate metaphor
for suicide bombing they're throwing
their children at us now Baker when you
hear the title mythmakers orbs of doom
what kind of game are you imagining I
would assume it's a hack and slash
dungeon crawling RPG no no it's actually
a ripoff of super monkey ball but
terrible oh look our favorite loading
screen is back the orbs of doom is a
total misnomer oh no it's not it's
really not I mean super monkey ball on
the wii was already not that fantastic
but these controls are just rented I
can't stop yourself from just pitching
over the cliff every two seconds oh and
I fell onto a JPEG
you can you can press B to break which
they had to add because otherwise the
game would be impossible you know all
those times I ever quit out of an xbox
live match before the loss got added
this is my penance so here we have pool
party made by those relentless purveyors
of quality itself p interactive let's
see level select yeah let's play in a
serial killers basement why not now of
course you could always just by we play
which has a perfectly functional pool
game and comes with a free Wii mote ok
hard to screw up pool how do you break
um you've got to hold down be and that
brings up your power meter and then you
hold down a and then you you move the
wiimote back and forth and it's gonna
raise or lower the the power meter and
then you push forward really really fast
um nothing's happening ok ah no push no
hold down are you holding on beat and a
oh it just worked but only when I like
cast it like it's a fishing pole wait
let me let me let me see this let me see
this thing seriously ok ah no no it's it
this is not work you're like flailing
around you look like back when people
have rabbit ears on the top there TV and
they're trying to move around to get
better reception should we go get some
tin foil or something I mean at least we
have this really soothing music to
listen to while we do this
color you know this counts as cosplay
whatever whatever can I can I get you to
Cape some like the little cat ears
you're jealous you jealous Baker well
you know I hope you had a good time they
play these terrible wii games would be
actually no no no i didn't oh it's like
it's like my heart he's wearing
ridiculous pink slippers right now
that's awesome hey we'll see you next
time i'm game life
you